ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND. BENNETT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA. BURKE CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAO CHEN. TO CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG. FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY. V.
LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA. WHEN
O'DONNELL. PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK. QUIRK
SILVA. RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO THEY ARE TO.
SMITH STONE TEAM VALIDATORS THE
APPROVAL. VOEPEL WALDRON WARD.
WEBER WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YES HERE CON YOU MOM IS HERE.
IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
ALMIGHTY GOD WE PRAY TO YOU
SEEKING YOUR HELP AND GUIDANCE.
TO ALLOW US TO SERVE OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS. BY NAVIGATING
THEM OUT OF WHATEVER
DIFFICULTIES THEY MAY BE FACING.
USE US TO FULFILL THEIR NEEDS.
ALLOW US TO BE A SOURCE OF HOPE
FOR THEM. IN THIS PANDEMIC. WE
PRAY TO YOU THAT YOU BLESS ALL
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. INCLUDING
FIRST RESPONDERS. THERE ARE
RISKING THEIR LIVES TO SERVE
THOSE IN NEED. SURE ALL THOSE
THAT ARE ILL DUE TO CULVERT.
AND ALLOW US TO THINK AND
REFLECT ABOUT THE LIVES LOST IN
OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I MEAN. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIDA AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
FLOOR. CALLING JOINING THE
PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. EIGHT ZERO- IS. FOR
ALL. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL GONNA ONE CENTER MONDAY
DECEMBER SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
PURSUANT TO THE PROVISIONS OF
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE AVERAGE
TWELVE O'CLOCK THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO REGULAR
SESSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WAS CALLED TO ORDER
BY SUE PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR
SESSION. DEFORMITY WITH THE LAW
THE FOLLOWING OFFICES WERE ALSO
PRESENT EMILY'S MINUTE CLERK
AND LISA BUCKLEY CHIEF SERGEANT
AT ARMS OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY REGULAR SESSION REPORTER
DAVID BOWMAN READING WILL CALL
THE CHIEF OR DIRECTOR THE
READING CLERK CALL THE ROLL
UPON THE APPS ON THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SELECT LOCAL RULES
CALLED FOR ALUMINUM REYES.
MOVES AND MISTER SECONDS THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS. DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESIDENT AND PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
PROVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. THIS RARE IF
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOTION. THANK YOU I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
COOLEY LACKEY CHILD HOLDEN
JONES SAWYER BIGELOW IN
RESEARCHING TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I MOVE TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ORDER ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY NINE THROUGH
EIGHTY EIGHT INCLUSIVE TO BE
PLACED ON THE SECOND READING
FILE THIS ACTION WILL POSITION
THESE BUDGET RELATED BILLS TO
BE TAKEN UP TO ADDRESS ISSUES
RELATED TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS.
MISS WALDRON FOR WHAT
PURPOSE- WE OBJECT ASTRAL CALL.
MISS WALDRON WITHHOLDS MS REYES
MOVES AND MR. BONTA SECONDS. ON
THE RULES SUSPENSION. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. MS RADIUS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MISS
WALDRON I KNOW THIS RADIUS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISS
WALDRON A NO VOTE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL MEMBERS THIS TAKES
FORTY ONE.
IS RACES ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. IS WALDRON AND NOW.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL EYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. MITHRAS
YOU ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZE. MS
RAMOS YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE. I
MOVE TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES TO
TAKE UP HIS H. R. SEVEN TODAY
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ADOPTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
GREAT MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE. THIS IS H. R. SEVEN.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES THE
CORPORATE HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES
RELATIVE TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES. MR MACE
MEMBERS. MISTER MAKER MAY OPEN
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS. I RISE
TODAY TO ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
REPUDIATING THE VIOLENCE THAT
OCCURRED LAST WEEK IN OUR
NATION'S CAPITAL. THE
DESECRATION OF DEMOCRACY. THE
DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY. AND
SADLY THE LOSS OF LIFE FOR
ALMOST TOO MUCH TO COMPREHEND.
WHY ALL BECAUSE OF THE BIG LIE.
THE PRESIDENT'S NONSTOP
UNSUBSTANTIATED AND FALSE
CLAIMS THAT THE ELECTION WAS
RIGGED AND FRAUDULENTLY STOLEN
FROM HIM WITH THE SPARKS THAT
LIT THE FIRE IT IS NOW INVOLVED
OUR NATION. WE HAVE COLLEAGUES
THAT TOOK TO SOCIAL MEDIA TO
DEFLECT BLAME. BUT THE IMAGES A
CONFEDERATE FLAGS MAGGA HATS
AND UBIQUITOUS Q. ANON SYMBOL
LEAVES NO DOUBT WHOSE MOB IT
WAS. EACH DAY MORE AND MORE
VIDEO FOOTAGE REVEALS A VERY
DARK PICTURE. FROM THE
MURDEROUS CHANCE CONSTRUCTING A
GALLOWS COMPLETE WITH NOOSE. TO
ZIP TIES PIPE BOMBS AND GUNS
AND WORSE. WATCHING A POLICE
OFFICER BEING BEATEN WITH AN
AMERICAN FLAG POLE. A POLICE
OFFICER BEATEN WITH AN AMERICAN
FLAG POLE. IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
MOB HAD BEEN CITED BY THE BIG
LIE. WELL AS EASY TO DEMONISE
THOSE CAUGHT UP IN THE FRENZY
OF HATE AND ANGER. THIS
AMERICAN CARNAGE LAYS AT THE
FEET. OF ONLY ONE PERSON. MANY
OF US IN THIS CHAMBER. I
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
COME FROM A MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITY BELIEVE ME. BEING
POOR AND WHITE FROM THE DESERT.
CARRIES MANY OF THE SAME
BURDENS AS GROWING UP POOR AND
BLACK OR BROWN FROM THE CITY. I
UNDERSTAND THOSE WHO FEEL THAT
THEY'VE BEEN LEFT BEHIND. I
HAVE FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO
THINK THAT NO ONE IS LISTENING
TO THEM IN THEIR FEARS THAT
THEY'RE LOSING THE COUNTRY.
THAT THEY LOVE. LET ME BE
CLEAR. THOSE WHO ARE COMMITTED
WHO COMMITTED THIS INSURRECTION
MUST BE PUNISHED TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW. BUT WE MUST
SHOW UNDERSTANDING FOR THOSE
RADICALIZED BY SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS BY NARCISSISTIC
POLITICIANS AND SHOCK JOCK
GRIFTERS HAVE GOTTEN RICH OFF
OF EXPLOITING PEOPLE'S EMOTIONS
AND FEARS. WE MUST SHOW THEM
LOVE AND ASK THEM TO COME HOME
TO AMERICA BUT HERE'S THEIR
VOICES. YES I'M SAYING THAT WE
NEED RECONCILIATION AND HEALING.
BUT THAT COMES AFTER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPENTANCE.
WE CAN BEGIN THAT PROCESS TODAY
BY STANDING UNITED IN THE
DEFENSE OF FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY AND ANNOUNCING THE
BIG LIE. AMERICA IS EXCEPTIONAL
AND I BELIEVE THAT. OUR LOVE OF
LIBERTY IS WHAT SETS US APART
FROM THE REST OF THE WORLD. BUT
LIBERTY CANNOT INDOOR WITHOUT
RESPONSIBILITY. MANY OF US
WOULD PREFERRED THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD TAKE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND RESIGN ON
HIS OWN VOLITION. SINCE HE
FAILED TO DO SO THE PEOPLE AND
THE REPRESENTATIVES MUST HOLD
HIM RESPONSIBLE WITH THE TOOLS
OF THE CONSTITUTION PROVIDES.
THE PRESIDENT INVITED THE
INSURRECTIONIST HE INCITED THEM
AND FOR TOO LONG HE DID NOTHING
TO STOP THEM. MEMBERS IF THAT
IS NOT AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE
BUT I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
THE WITHIN EACH OF US TOOK
WEEKS AGO TO SUPPORT DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES US TO
TAKE ACTION SO TODAY. LET US
RAISE OUR VOICE AND ACT IN
SOLIDARITY AS ONE NATION TO
HOLD THE PRESIDENT TO ACCOUNT.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE AND ASKED BY LIKE THE
CLERK TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISTER MESS.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
MISTER GIBSON IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
ANDMEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SUPPORT FOR HR SEVEN. AS A
PRINCIPLE CALLED. I'M ASKING
FOR THE IMMEDIATE REMOVAL OF
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP MY
RESIGNATION ORDERED ACTING. THE
TWENTY FIFTH AMENDMENT OR
IMPEACHMENT OR CONVICTION.
MEMBERS WHAT WE ALL SAW LAST
WEDNESDAY WAS A DIRECT ASSAULT
ON THE DEMOCRACY OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. I'M
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVING THAT OUR
VOICE IN CALIFORNIA BY IN
SUPPORT OF HR SEVEN CAN
CERTAINLY SAID ALLOW MESSAGE A
STRONG MESSAGE. THAT THIS WHAT
TRANSPIRED ON WEDNESDAY. WE'RE
FIX PEOPLE'S LIVES WERE LOST.
INCLUDING A CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICER. INDIVIDUAL WHO SWORE
TO PROTECT WAS A VICTIM OF WHAT
TRANSPIRED. THAT EMULATED FROM
THE HIGHEST OFFICE OF THIS LAND.
IT WAS GREEN LIGHTED. FOR
PEOPLE TO COME TOGETHER. AN
ATTACK. ARE YOU NOT A STATE
CAPITOL. WE CAN DISAGREE WE CAN
BE ABLE TO HELP PARTY LINES
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS. BUT WHAT
TRANSPIRED. I SAT IN HORROR.
BUT OUR NATION CAPITAL WAS
UNDER ATTACK BECAUSE BIG CHEAP
COMMANDING OFFICER GAVE THE
GREEN LIGHT. VIGILANTE. TO
ATTACK OUR DEMOCRACY. TO PUT
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN JEOPARDY. WE
CANNOT STAND BY AND WATCH THIS
HAPPEN. WE BELIEVE STRONGLY. IN
H. R. SEVEN AND WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION BEFORE THIS BODY
CALIFORNIA COULD NOT BE SILENT.
DR BURGER KING SAYS THAT
SILENCE IS A FORMER TRAIL WE
HAVE THE POWER TO COLLECTIVELY
BILLION ALL BOYS TOGETHER ON
THIS FLOOR AND A LOUD MESSAGE.
THAT WE WILL NOT STAND FOR NOT
ONLY ATTACK AGAINST OUR
DEMOCRACY. BUT THIS COUNTRY IT
HAS LEFT THIS COUNTRY
VULNERABLE THE OTHER TAX
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. THIS RESOLUTION TO
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE THAT THIS
PRESIDENT NEEDS TO RESIGN. THIS
PRESIDENT NEEDS OR THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF BOTH THE TWENTY
FIFTH AMENDMENT. I DO THE RIGHT
THING IT IS TIME FOR THIS
COUNTRY T. HILL AND THIS
COUNTRY NEEDS ZERO NOW. STOP
ASKING THAT YOU SUPPORT HR
SEVEN WHICH I ABLE THANK YOU
MEMBERS. EGGMAN GIPSON MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I LIKE- MY COLLEAGUE IS
INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION.
GREW UP. WHY IS WELL. IT IS
SEEN THE FACE OF POVERTY IS
LIVE THE FACE OF POVERTY AND
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT'S LIKE. TO
GROW UP IN ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT'S FOR GOTTEN. BY THE
POLITICIANS THAT REPRESENT US.
IS THE FIRST MILLENNIAL COMBAT
VETERAN WITH A PURPLE HEART
ELECTED TO STATE OFFICE IN THIS
COUNTRY. I FIND WHAT HAPPENED.
OUR NATIONAL CAPITAL COMPLETELY
APPALLING. I TWEETED ABOUT IT
SAYING THAT VIOLENCE IS NOT
PROTEST. AND I AGREE WITH MANY
OF THE THINGS THE AUTHOR IS SET.
WHAT I DO NOT AGREE WITH. IS
THE FACT THAT THE TWENTY FIFTH
AMENDMENT TIMELINE SIMPLY IS
NOT THERE. REGARDLESS OF HOW
MANY OF ALL OF US WISH IT WAS.
WE HAVE A LAME DUCK PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE DYING OF COVERT.
WE HAE AREAS IN OUR STATE.
WHERE FAMILY STILL CAN'T PUT
FOOD ON THEIR TABLE. WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT I STILL
LIVE IN THIRD WORLD CONDITIONS
AND DON'T HAVE RUNNING WATER.
BUT INSTEAD THE FIRST THING WE
DO ON THE FLOOR IN CALIFORNIA.
IS THERE A POLITICAL PUNCH AT A
LAME DUCK. I THINK THAT'S TO
BLAME I THINK THE FIRST THING
WE SHOULD BE DOING IS HELPING
FAMILIES. WITH COLBY. LOOKING
TO GET OUR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL
GETTING THIS VACCINE NOW. GOOD
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
STILL SITTING IN BOXES. WE ARE
FRONT LINE WORKERS THAT NEED
THE VACCINE BUT NO WE'RE GOING
TO SPEND MILLIONS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS YOUR DAHLE A CITIES. TO
GO PARTIAL LANE. THIS IS A
LIGHT YOUR OLD THAN THIS. I
BELIEVE IN PUTTING OVER. AND
THIS IS PAUL OVER PEOPLE LAST
FOR NO. MR COOLEY YOUR
RECOGNITION OR CHAMBER. CALLING
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. I THINK WHAT WE SAW
LAST WEEK WAS A POLLING. I DO
HOWEVER BELIEVE THIS IS A VERY
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR COURSE
LIKE THIS TO COME BEFORE THE
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY. IT'S A
TIME TO REFLECT UPON THE NATURE
OF THE OFFICE WE SUITED. YES
THE RESOLUTION IS A MIRROR.
LET'S JUST LOOK AT RECENT
CIRCUMSTANCES LAST WEEK
CONDUCTED UP TO IT. BUT I
ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS A MIRROR IN YOUR
OWN HEARTS WHAT IS THE NATURE
OF THE OFFICE THAT WE STANDING.
AND SINCE THIS IS THE FIRST DAY
OF TWENTY. TWENTY ONE AS WE
START THE LEGISLATURE. I
ACTUALLY STAND A PAIR WE DON'T
HAVE OUR KIDS AT SCHOOL MY
GRANDKIDS ARE NOT SCHOOL AHEAD
OF. MAKES PERCENT. BUT I
REMEMBER THE FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL. WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE ON
THE FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL MY
FIRST DAY IN JOB. HOW I KNOW.
THE FUTURE THE PROCESS. THAT
OFFERS. THIS IS THE FIRST DAY
OF SCHOOL FOR US TO COME BACK
INTO TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AFTER
TWO HOLD LAST YEAR. AND SET OUR
SIGHTS HIGH. I DO AGREE WITH MY-
THAT WE HAVE A BROAD AGENDA THE
NEEDS TO BE A- TO THE- BENEFIT
OF EVERY CALIFORNIA. ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. I AGREE WITH
THAT. BUT YOU KNOW LITTLE OVER
A MONTH AGO WE STOOD IN THE-
HOLD ONE CENTER. WE LIVED IN
OUR ARMS WHAT WE SAY. THANK
ABOUT THOSE WORDS. YOU MADE A
NOTE WE ALL MADE A NOTE. I DO
SOLEMNLY SWEAR THIS IS NOT DONE
LIGHT HEARTEDLY. THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND. WHAT WHAT
IS IT WILL TAKE A LITTLE TO
SUPPORT AND DEFEND BUT THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. AND THE POSSIBLE USES
DATA CALIFORNIA. THAT I WILL
BEAR TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE.
THIS MEANS THERE IS A CONSTANCY
TO THE FAITH ALLEGIANCE IS NOT
LIKE WHEN I WAS A LITTLE KID I
PLAYED TAG I DO ACCESS OR NOT I
WILL BE CONSIST. TRUTH FOR AND
ALLEGIANCE TO COST I STAY
CONSISTED OF CAL. THE I TAKE
THIS ALL THE FREE WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION OR PURPOSE
EVASION. THAT WILL. WELL OF
BASICALLY DESTROY THE DUTIES BY
TERM NOT THERE THAT WAS RO. WE
ALL TOOK THE OR WHAT THAT WE
TOOK OURSELVES OUT OF. REGULAR
LIFE. IN A POSITION OF TRUST
AND SERVICE AND DEREK IS A
BEYOND OURSELVES. THIS IS THE
AMERICAN WAY IT IS THE MARK TO
GIVE A WAY. AGES AGO IN THE
MEAT TIME WE HAVE A COLD THAT
WAS COMMON OF. YOUR TO GOING TO
BE LOYAL TO YOU'RE DON'T WHAT
WHAT YOU GIRLS WAS. THE IS NOT
THE AMERICA WAY. THAT IS WHAT
WE CAN OUR FUTURE ON OWES OF
FIELD YOU. BUT IT IS ON THE OLD
TO SOME THE TO WHICH I'VE IS UP.
IN THIS RED. FARAS WHEN WE HOLD
THAT MIRROR TO A. THE SIX
GEORGE ORWELL WROTE AN ESSAY.
THE GREW OUT OF HIS LIFE IN
INDIA. WHERE ONE MORNING.
PEOPLE OF HIS VILLAGE CAME TO
HIM SAYING SOMETHING
DISTRESSING IT HAPPENED. AND HE
NEEDED ACT INSTANTLY UPON. WELL
IT WAS AN ANIMAL HAD TRAMPLED
SOMEBODY'D KILLED. BECAUSE IT
WAS THE SPRING HE SORT OF
THOUGHT WELL ASSIST BRING
ANIMALS GET RESTAURANTS THE
TIME APPROPRIATIONS. EVERYONE
KNOWS YOU JUST STAY CLEAR OF
THEM AT THIS TIME. HE REASONS
IT OUT. THAT I'M TRYING TO GET
ATTRACT THIS ANIMAL DOWN AND
IT'S GOING TO BE FINE. AND I
COULD JUST GO AWAY AND HANG UP
MY HAT AND I GOT MY GUN. THIRTY
SECONDS COOLEY AS SHE WALKS A
GREAT THRONG OF PEOPLE
SURROUNDS IN. HE FINDS THE
ANIMAL. ALL IS PEACEFUL BUT
THERE IS THAT CROWN. AND IT
CONCLUDES IT WILL BE YOUR THE
SAKE YOU HAVE TO ACT RECKLESSLY
YOU HAVE TO RESPOND TO THE
CROWD. AND THEN WHERE THE STORY
ACTUALLY. THE ESSAY SHOOTING AN
ELEPHANT. AGAINST HIS BETTER
JUDGMENT HE SHOT AN ELEPHANT
WHICH WAS VITAL THAT COMMUNITY.
AND THEN HAD TO SIT BY WILL
HAVE A LINGERING DEATH. I
ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THIS IDEA
THAT WE AS PUBLIC OFFICIALS DID
NOT TO SHOULD DEVELOP WHEN A
RATIONAL MIND SAYS. IT'S NOT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO THAT WE
NEED TO TAKE A DIFFERENT COURSE
AND NOT JUST FOLLOW THE
CLAMORING CROWD. WHAT DO WE
NEED TO GO BACK TO OUR
CONSTITUTION. AND THAT LED BY
WHICH WE SEPARATE US FROM ALL
OTHER MANKIND. IS THE ISSUE FOR
THE STATE FIRE CHEN AYE VOTE-
TO LIVE OUT OUR OLD. AND A FIRM
THAT WE LIVE IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY DOT THE. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU MISS COOLEY.
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
ACTUALLY MOTIVATED BY THE WORDS
OF OUR LAST SPEAKER HERE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS RESOLUTION
AS A REFLECTIVE OF WHO A
REFLECTION OF WHO WE ARE. THIS
ISN'T REALLY OUR FIRST ACTION
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
BUSINESS- THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US AND WASHINGTON DC IN THE
POLITICS AND THE POLICIES THAT
HAVE COME OUT OF THERE THIS IS
A CONTINUATION OF OUR POSITION-
TO REALLY MAKE IT A POINT TO
SAY THAT WE DO NOT STAND FOR-
THE POLITICS AND THE POLICIES.
THAT HAVE BEEN HURTING PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY- THROUGHOUT THE
LAST FOUR YEARS AND I THINK
THIS PANDEMIC CLEARLY IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THAT ECONOMY
THAT WILL HAVE TO FOCUS ON
PURELY IS A REFLECTION OF THAT
AND SO I ALSO HOPE THAT THE
TAKEAWAY HERE ISN'T THAT- YOU
KNOW BUT WE ARE MAKING A
COMPARISON BETWEEN POOR WHITE
PEOPLE AND POOR. PEOPLE OF
COLOR BECAUSE THAT'S NOT I
BELIEVE SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ENTERTAIN OUR DEBATE
BECAUSE WE CARE AND THERE IS A
BIG DIFFERENCE WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT BUT I WANTED JUST TO SAY
THAT I APPRECIATE- THE AUTHOR-
WHO I SHARE THE COACHELLA
VALLEY GEOGRAPHY IN
REPRESENTATION FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD. HE IS-
DEMONSTRATED A LOT OF COURAGE-
DURING THIS TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS IS JUST.
ONE MORE INDICATION OF. HE
MORAL COMPASS AND HOW HE FEELS
ABOUT THE PUBLIC SERVICE THAT
HE'S BEEN ELECTED TO DO. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FOR I STAND WITH YOU
AND EVERYONE ELSE. IN SUPPORT
OF HR SEVEN ANNOUNCED THAT
EVERYONE SUPPORT THIS AS WELL.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION MISTER MAYES
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. Q.
AYE MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE- THE GOOD
GOOD DEBATE THE GOOD DISCUSSION
ON THIS- I- LIKE. ALL OF US A
WATCHING LAST WEEK WERE WAS
HORRIFIED. AT WHAT HAPPENED ON
ARE AT ON THE STEPS OF OUR
NATION'S CAPITAL THE PEOPLE
BREAKING IN THE NATION'S
CAPITAL IN PEOPLE LOSING THEIR
LIFE WE'VE ALL SPOKEN. SPOKEN
OF THAT. I THINK THE REAL
QUESTION IS. IS THAT A
BEGINNING OF SOMETHING. OR THE
END OF SOMETHING OR IS IT THE
BEGINNING OF SOMETHING. AS A
DEMOCRATIC BODY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
REPRESENTS FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE. IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY. TO GO ON RECORD
TWO ONE NOTICE ON WHICH SIDE.
THAT WE WHERE WE STAND DO WE
STAND FOR THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. WHERE DO WE STAND
FOR SOMETHING ELSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AGAIN FOR THAT
RESPECTFUL DEBATE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. MISTER
MAZES AFTER PERSONAL BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. HOME AUTHORS. ON HR SEVEN
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER
ROLE THERE ARE FORTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MISTER GIBSON IS
GOING TO BE ADDED AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR. MEMBERS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR PLEASE
NOTIFY THE DESK. AND WITH THAT
WE ARE OING TO TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THIS. HOUSE
RESOLUTION CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT ABOUT.
THE CLERK WELL
CLOSER ROLE HIGHS FIFTY ONE NO.
SIX HOUSE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS. AND THAT YOUR
CONVERSATION SEIZE. PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS MEMBERS WHERE AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERSTO READ IN
PREPARATION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES ALL OF ALL OF US WHO
HAVE LOST SOMEONE NEAR AND DEAR.
I HAVE NO DOUBT HAD THE
EXPERIENCE THAT IN ITS WAKE WE
CANNOT UNDERSTAND HOW THE WORLD
JUST GOES ON NORMALLY. WHEN A
BIG PERSON HAS LEFT OUR LINE.
IT'S KIND OF A COMMON PLACE OF
HUMAN EXPERIENCE. TODAY'S
INSTITUTION WE ARE MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO NOT ACT IN THAT
MANNER. BECAUSE THREE WEEKS AGO
TOMORROW WE LOST A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR COMMUNITY-
LAWRENCE LARRY PATRICK LUTHER.
MR LITTLE WAS THE AUTOMOTIVE
POOL MANAGER DOWN THE BASEMENT.
AND SO TODAY WE ARE JOURNAL HIS
MEMORY AS SOMEONE HAVE PLAYED
SUCH A- IN ONE RESPECT SO.
TECHNICAL ROLE IN THE WORKERS
INSTITUTION GET REALLY SUCH A
BIG ROLE. AS GOVERNOR'S.
LAWMAKERS TRAVEL TOOL FOR ALL
PAST SEVEN PROSTITUTES IN THE
BASEMENT. AND CHOREOGRAPHED AT
ALL SO THERE'S JUST NO FRICTION.
BUT AS THEY ARRIVE WHATEVER THE
THOUGHTS ARE ON THEIR MIND THEY
COULD GO DIRECTLY TO WORK ACT
UPON THEM AND NOT NOT
DISTRACTED BY. ANNOYING
ANNOYING THINGS. FULLER PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY SECOND
AT THE AGE OF FIFTY EIGHT.
AFTER A BATTLE WITH COVERT
NINETEEN. I WILL ADD IN MY LIFE
HE WAS ONE OF FOUR PEOPLE WHO
DIED IN DECEMBER BUT I DO WELL.
IT WAS A BAD BOND. VERY WAS A
NATIVE SACRAMENTO BORDER SYLVIA
AND LAWRENCE LUNA JUNIOR IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. HE HAD
WORKED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR NEARLY FORTY
YEARS. HE BEGAN HIS TO THE
SYSTEM WITH THE PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY. BY
EIGHTY EIGHT HE MOVED THE
PARTNER GENERAL SERVICES WHERE
HE WOULD GO ON TO SERVE IN THE
CAPITOL GARAGE GROUP. AND THEN
AS I SAID OFFICIALLY BECOMING
THE MANAGER OF THAT CREW. ON
ALL OF OUR BEHALF. HE WAS KNOWN
AS A- FROM HIS PRESENCE THERE.
AS A FRIENDLY. DEPENDABLE TEAM
MEMBER. WELCOME GOVERNOR'S
ARRIVING MEMBERS OF THEIR
STAFFS THAT HELP CHOREOGRAPH
THE CONSTABLE CARS TO THE
BASEMENT. MAKING FOR SAFETY AND
SMOOTH OPERATION. HE IN HIS
GARAGE STEP PARTNERS- MORE HARM
ME ROBERT TERRY WITH THEIR
SITUATION SHE'S BE COLLEAGUES.
AIMED AT DALY TO ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S UNFOLDING THE
WORK. AND THE CAPITAL'S
UNFOLDING WERE. ON BEHALF OF
THE FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS
BY KEEPING ALL ARRIVE SAFE AND
WELL MANAGED SAID. HE'S
CHEERFUL ATTITUDE LEADERSHIP
AND PROFESSIONALISM DURING THE
MANY. WILL BE SORELY MISSED BY
ALL WHO KNEW HIM. FLOWERS ARE
IN THE BASEMENT TODAY'S YOU GO
UP THERE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
MERRY LUNAR. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS PARENTS SYLVIA MORRIS
JUNIOR. HIS SISTERS MARIE
THERESA MONICA AND A VET. HIS
FOUR CHILDREN ANDREA REPORTER
STEPHANIE AND DANIEL. AND NOT
TO BE FORGOTTEN CHáVEZ A
PAYDAY HIS GIRLFRIEND. AND HIS
LOVING EXTENDED FAMILY I
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
LAWRENCE PATRICK LUTHER OUR
PARTNER IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
FOR MANY YEARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEASURE COOLEY.
MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL ON REMAINING
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. PLEASE
REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS MEMBERS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR. PLEASE GIVE A
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION YOUR
COLLEAGUES. WILL BE ADJOURNING
IN THE MEMORY. MR LACKEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WHO MEMBERS IT IS WITH
A HEAVY HEART. BUT OUR RIGHTS
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF OFFICER
AND YOU'RE NO LESS. PASSED AWAY
DECEMBER SECOND FAR TOO EARLY
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN. HIS
MOTHER IS A RECENT RETIREE THAT
I WORKED WITH FOR MANY MANY
YEARS. HIS DAD IS NOW A PD AS
BROTHERS A HIGHWAY PATROL.
MEMBER IT'S TRULY A LAW
ENFORCEMENT FAMILY. AND IT WAS
KNOWN FOR HIS DEDICATION TO
BOTH HIS JOB BUT TO THIS
COMMUNITY TO IS WIFE. HERE'S A
FOUR YEAR VETERAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. AND
HAD BEEN A BORDER OFFICER SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. HE
RECEIVED MULTIPLE COMMENDATIONS
FOR HIS EXCELLENT WORK
PERFORMANCE. INCLUDING HONORS
AS AN ANALOG VALLEY OFFICER THE
QUARTER JUST A FEW MONTHS.
BEFORE HIS LIFE WAS TAKEN.
ABOVE ALL ELSE. AND EVALUATORS
FAMILY AND AS COMMUNITY. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE TAYLOR.
HIS SISTER NIKKI HIS BROTHER
OFFICER CODY ORNELAS HIS UNCLE
CAPITAL OF CAPTAIN ANDREAS
ANALYSIS AND AS PARENTS OFFICER.
AND ARTURO OR KNOWLEDGE. AND I
ASKED WE RESPECTFULLY INJURED
IN THE MEMORY. OF OFFICER RANDY
OR DALLAS TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKING MISTER
CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF DAVID BARRON A
JOURNALIST A PUBLIC SERVANT AND
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST. MISTER
BERRY WAS BORN IN EAST LOS
ANGELES ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINTH NINETEEN FORTY ONE AND
PASSED AWAY ON NOVEMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY NINE. HE ATTENDED EAST
LA COLLEGE AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES WHERE HE
RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN JOURNALISM AND
COMMUNICATIONS IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE. HIS PASSION FOR
JOURNALISM LED HIM TO WORK AS A
WRITER AND EDITOR FOR THE
BELVEDERE CITIZEN IN EAST SIDE
JOURNAL FOR MANY YEARS AFTER
COLLEGE. IT WOULD LATER GO ON
TO PUBLISH THE MONTEREY PARK
JOURNAL IN THE WEST VALLEY
JOURNAL FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
MISTER BEHREND MET HIS WIFE AT
EAST LA COLLEGE AND THE TWO
MARRIED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE. THEY MOVED TO THE CITY
OF MONTEREY PARK IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX WHERE HE BEGAN HIS
LONG CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE
TO THE COMMUNITY. HE SERVED ON
AMARI PARK PLANNING COMMISSION
BEFORE BEING ELECTED MORE A
PARK CITY CLERK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. MONTH ISN'T MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS CITY CLERK
MISTER BERENDT WAS CREDITED
WITH BRINGING ELECTRONIC TOUCH
SCREEN VOTING TO THE CITY. HE
RETIRED FROM HIS LONG CAREER AS
CITY CLERK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AFTER TWENTY FIVE YEARS. THE
WITH DEDICATED TO CONTINUE HIS
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY HE
DOES SERVE FOR SIX YEARS ON THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES FOR THE MARIE
PARK BROOKMEYER. LIBRARY AND
WAS A MEMBER OF THE MAURY PARK
LIBRARY FOUNDATION. MISTER
BARRON IS SURVIVED BY HIS
BELOVED WIFE MARY ALLEN. FOUR
CHILDREN TEN GRANDCHILDREN AND
TWO GREAT GRANDCHILDREN HE
LEAVES BEHIND AN ENDURING
LEGACY OF SERVICE TO THE CITY
OF MONTEREY PARK AND THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DAVID
BARRON. THANK YOU MISTER SHALL.
AND MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR FIRST
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU
RETURN IN THE MEMORY OF WENDY
GORDON. WHEN HE WAS A TALENTED
JOURNALISTS AND PRESS SECRETARY.
SHE WAS ALSO A BELOVED WIFE
EITHER A MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY. SHE WAS PART OF MY
STAFF FROM THE MY FIRST DAYS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED. A NATIVE OF
PASADENA SHE WAS BORN OCTOBER
TENTH NINETEEN FORTY NINE. AND
PASADENA SUNLAND TO HOSPITAL.
HOW TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL SHE
ATTENDED UCLA WHERE SHE
RECEIVED HER BACHELOR'S AND
MASTER'S IN FILM AND TELEVISION.
SHE BEGAN HER TELEVISION CAREER
AS A REPORTER IN PEORIA
ILLINOIS IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. SHE SOON WENT ON TO
BE THE FIRST FEMALE ANCHOR A K.
O. I. AND TV AND PORTLAND
OREGON. THERE SHE REPORTED ON
THE ERUPTION OF MOUNT ST HELENS
FROM THE GROUND AND HAD HER OWN
TALK SHOW. SHE JOINED A CAGE
DAY NOW KAY CAL THE LOS ANGELES
AS AN EVENING NEWS ANCHOR IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY. IT WAS WHILE
SHE WAS ANCHORING IN LOS
ANGELES THAT SHE MET MICHAEL
GOTTLIEB. DURING AN INTERVIEW.
AT THE TIME HE WAS WELL KNOWN
FOR IDENTIFIED AIDS AS A NEW
DISEASE. THEY LATER MARRIED AND
HAVE ONE DAUGHTER JULIE. SHE
WAS WELL RESPECTED JOURNALISTS
AND ATAT AT A TIME WHEN THERE
WERE VERY FEW FEMALE ANCHORS.
HER PROFESSIONALISM
INTELLIGENCE AND DYNAMIC
PERSONALITY MADE HER A STANDOUT
THE LEAD TO VARIOUS AWARDS
INCLUDING EMMYS. AFTER RETIRING
FROM JOURNALISM IN NINETEEN
NINETY SHE SERVED AS PRESS
SECRETARY FOR SENATORS JACK
SCOTT. AND ANTHONY PORTANTINO
AND MYSELF. WHILE WORKING IN MY
OFFICE HER TALENTS DIDN'T JUST
BENEFIT ME. SHE ELEVATED THE
WHOLE STAFF. AND WITH HER
LEADERSHIP AND INSIGHT. I'LL
TRY TO WORK SHE WAS AN AVID
GARDENER. WORST BACK RIDER
THE COMMUNITY. THE CITY OF
PASADENA HER FRIENDS AND FAMILY
WILL MISS HER DEARLY I THANK
YOU FOR JOINING IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN AND YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY AT THE CATO ROSE
MATSUI OG. TRAILBLAZER AND TRUE
PUBLIC SERVANT. SHE WAS BORN
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY EIGHT A LOS ANGELES TO
JAPANESE IMMIGRANTS AND PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONLY TWO DAYS SHY
OVER EIGHTY SECOND BIRTHDAY.
SHE WAS A WOMAN OF VISION AND
NORMA'S CHARACTER. WHEN SHE WAS
A CHILD HER FAMILY WAS SENT TO
SANTA ANITA DETENTION CENTER.
AND A CONCENTRATION CAMP IN
ARKANSAS DUE TO THE RACES
EXECUTIVE ORDER. NINE ZERO SIX
SIX. THERE'S THE WITNESS MANY
SINK INTO DESPAIR AFTER LOSING
THEIR HOMES JOBS. IS SO MUCH
THAT THEY WORK FOR. AFTER
LEAVING THE CAMP LIFE CONTINUE
TO BE DIFFICULT FOR HER FAMILY.
BUT THEY OVERCAME POVERTY AND
RACISM TO BUILD A LIFE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. AND FIGHT. FOR
CITIZENSHIP. FROM A YOUNG AGE
HE PROVED HE WAS SMART A LEADER
AND A FIGHTER ATTRIBUTES ARE
PARENTS NURTURED IN HER WHICH
SHE LED WHICH LED HER TO
EVENTUALLY PURSUE A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN EDUCATION LAW DEGREE
AND A LIFE OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
LIKE SO MANY CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS DESPITE THE CRUELTY
INFLICTED ON HER FAMILY. BY THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SHE CHOSE AGAINST VIOLENCE
VENGEANCE OR DESPAIR. AND
INSTEAD CHOSE TO WORK TO CREATE
A BETTER WORLD. AN EXAMPLE THAT
IS ESPECIALLY NOTABLE AFTER
EVENTS OF LAST WEEK. SHE TURNED
OUT OF POSITION TO WORK AS A
PROSECUTOR TO WORK AT USC'S
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. THERE SHE BECAME O
COUNSEL ON THE LANDMARK SERATO
VERSUS PRES CASE WHICH
BOLSTERED EDUCATION EQUALITY.
SHE WENT ON TO WORK FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN VARIOUS
ROLES WHERE SHE CREATED A
SIGNIFICANT LAW ENFORCEMENT USE
OF FORCE POLICY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE LAPD AND CREATED
NEW DIVISIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SELECT COMMISSION ON
IMMIGRATION AND REFUGEE POLICY.
BECAME INFLUENTIAL IN THE FIGHT
TO RECOGNIZE MAN MENDOZA
MANZANAR. AS HISTORICAL SITE.
IN FOR REPARATIONS. SHE ALSO
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN CREATING
STRONGER DRUGS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND HATE CRIME
POLICIES. AFTER SERVING IN
WASHINGTON DC SHE CAME HOME TO
LA TO BE THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMAN POLICE
COMMISSIONER AND ADVOCATE FOR
CAUSES SHE BELIEVED IN. THERE
ARE MANY NOTABLE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS I HAVEN'T EVEN
MENTIONED. SO INSTEAD I WILL
SUM IT UP BY SAYING. I KNOW
BECAUSE OF HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND WORK THE CITY STATE AND
COUNTRY IS BETTER OFF FOR ALL
OF US. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
THOMAS OCHI- LOVING AND
SUPPORTIVE HUSBAND. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING IN HONOR OF THIS
BEAUTIFUL REMARKABLE PERSON
RESULT. THANK YOU MISTRIALS IN
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
MEMORY. YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RICE TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF ROSE
MUCH TO EAT OF G. THE COMMUNITY
LEADER AND ADVOCATE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS JUSTICE REFORM AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. MANY OF WHAT ARE
WE GONNA TALK ABOUT MR HOLDEN
PRODUCT. OF FROM A PERSONAL
STANDPOINT AS A YOUNG MAN
WORKING IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WHERE I MET ROSE OKEY.
BOB SHE WAS ALWAYS ONE. THAT
WOULD COME TO ME AND WHISPERED
IN MY EAR. PEARLS OF WISDOM. TO
AN APP YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN
PUBLIC SERVANT SHE DIDN'T NEED
TO DO THAT. I WOULD LIE TO
BELIEVE SHE SAW SOMETHING IN ME
THAT I DIDN'T SEE EARLY ON IN
MY CAREER. BUT SHE WAS LIKE
THAT. SHE WAS THE KIND OF
PERSON THAT WENT OUT OF HER
WAY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY. HEADED EQUAL CHANCE
IN A SOCIETY AND IT WAS BECAUSE
OF THE LATINO UPRISING IN THE
SCHOOLS AND IN IN SIXTIES
THAT'S WHAT DROVE HER TO BECOME%
A LAWYER. SO SHE COULD COME
BACK AND FIGHT IN COMBAT ALL
THE RACISM THAT SHE'S NOT ON
THAT SHE HAD EXPERIENCE. BUT
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT OTHERS FROM
OTHER COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE.
AND I KNEW SHE WAS SOMEBODY
IMPORTANT IN THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE. BECAUSE WHEN SHE WALKED
INTO A ROOM. WHEN SHE WALKED
INTO A ROOM YOU COULD ALMOST
SEE EVERYBODY RICE BECAUSE SHE
HAD THAT MUCH POWER THAT MUCH
SIGNIFICANCE AND YOU KNEW YOU
WERE DEALING WITH A PERSON OF
SUBSTANCE THAT YOU NEEDED TO
DEAL WITH. WHEN YOU LOVE WHICH
KILLED SHE FOR CHEAP DAVIS IF
YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT CHEAP
DAVIS DURING THAT TIME. YOU
KNOW THAT SHE WAS SOMEONE THAT
YOU HAD TO RECKON WITH AND SHE
DEVELOP USE OF FORCE POLICIES
AFTER LAPD'S SHOT YOU'LL LOVE A
THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD BLACK
MOTHER WIDOW. AT A TIME WHEN WE
DIDN'T HAVE CAMERAS. THE SHOW
WHAT WAS REALLY GOING ON
SOMETHING A LOT OF PEOPLE ANY
AFTERMARKET LATINO. UNITY KNEW
ABOUT BUT NO ONE REALLY
BELIEVES. WHEN SHE WAS SHE
WOULD BEND THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMEN TO SERVE AS AN
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL AT
THE DIRECTOR DEPARTMENTS
JUSTICE. RELATIONS SERVICE ROSE
OVERSAW THE AGENCY'S COMPLEX
THE MAJORITY OF WHICH INVOLVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT PRACTICES LONG
BEFORE WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
NOW THROUGHOUT HER CAREER AND
COMMUNITY RELATIONS DIRECTOR
ROSE WORK TO ENSURE
IMPROVEMENTS TO. THE SOUTH FOR
MAYOR. POLICE COMMUNITY
RELATIONS PLEASE INTEGRITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HATE CRIMES
AND RACE RELATIONS. THAT WAS IN
THE NINETIES BEFORE SHE
RETURNED TO LOS ANGELES IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE ROSE BECAME THE
FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN TRUSTEE
FOR THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BAR
ASSOCIATION WITH AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
BAR ASSOCIATION. AMONG MANY
WELL DESERVED AWARDS AND SHE
DESERVE MANY. ROSE RECEIVED THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ATTORNEY GENERAL RAND
OFF AWARD FOR DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE. THE NATIONAL ASIAN
AMERICAN LEGAL CONSORTIUM
AMERICAN COURAGE AWARD. AND THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES
COMMENDATION FOR OUTSTANDING.
SERVICE I WISH EVERYONE I WISH
THAT EVERYONE IN HIS IN HIS
CHAMBER HAD OPPORTUNITY. TO
MEET ROSE OCHI. EVERY IN HERE
HAD MET HER IT WOULD BE BETTER
FOR. YES SHE SERVED BY HER.
THOMAS OKAY. CHIU LEAVING
BEHIND A OF COMMUNITY AT. AND
FIGHTING AGAINST IN. ROCHE WITH
A LOT OF US DO NOT LET ANYONE
DEFINE WHO YOU ARE. OR LIMIT
YOUR ASPIRATIONS NEVER LET
ANYONE DO THAT. MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY
OF ROSE MATSUMAE OKEY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
AND MISTER MURATSUCHI IN THE
REAR CHAMBER YOUR ALSO
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE UP. TOO MUCH MORE
OF. OUR COLLEAGUES TIME TO BUT
I JUST WANTED TO- WITH
PERMISSION OF A PARK COLLEAGUES
FROM PASADENA AND FROM SOUTH
LOS ANGELES I WANT TO ADD ON.
MARITA THE PRASARANA TO LOSS OF
A FRIEND ROSE MATERIAL G. FOR
ANYONE IN THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY YOU KNEW WHO ROSE-
SHE WAS. LIKE THAT'S JOHN SORRY
SAID WHEN SHE WALKED IN THE
ROOM YOU KNEW THAT SHE WAS
THERE SHE HAS SUCH PRESENCE SHE
WAS A STRONG ARTICULATE
BEAUTIFUL WOMAN. SHE WAS BORN
IN BOYLE HEIGHTS. AND AT THREE
YEARS OLD SHE WAS SENT TO THE
ROAR INTERMENT CAMP IN ARKANSAS.
AND LIKE BILL FOR JOKER THE
FORMER CEO OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SAID ME THAT REALLY
BURNED. HER LIFELONG COMMITMENT
TO FIGHT FOR THE UNDERDOG IN
OUR SOUL. I JUST WANTED TO.
THANK ROSE OCHI I WAS ONE OF
MANY PEOPLE ALONG WITH MR
HOLDEN ALONG WITH MR JONES
SAWYER SO MANY PEOPLE. AND THE
COMMUNITY WHOSE LIVES HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED. WERE MENTOR BY ROSE-
G. THANK YOU ROSE. THANK YOU MR
MURATSUCHI AND MR BIGELOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO HONOR
THE MEMORY OF A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE FORMER CHP OFFICER MIKE I
ALL OF. HE PASSED AWAY DUE TO
COMPLICATIONS FROM THE DREADED
COVERT NINETEEN VIRUS. MANY OF
US HERE TODAY HAVE GOT SO MANY
FRIENDS WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY THIS. ARABLE
HORRIBLE VIRUS GROWING UP NEAR
SAN BRUNO MIGHT MATHIS FUTURE
WIFE IN HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART
NANCY. BEFORE BEING SWORN IN AS
US OFFICER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. HE AND HIS-
DEDICATED HE DEDICATED HIS LIFE
EFFORTS TO ENSURING THE SAFETY
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC WHILE
ALSO BEING A DEDICATED MEMBER
TO HIS COMMUNITY. HE WORKED HIS
WAY UP TO BECOME A LIEUTENANT
AND SOON AFTER MY TRANSFERRED
TO THE CHP OFFICE IN SONORA.
WHERE HE BECAME ITS COMMANDER.
THERE HE AND HIS WIFE MADE
THEIR LONG. AND- ILLUSTRIOUS
HOME IN THE HISTORIC CITY OF
SONORA AND RAISED TWO DAUGHTERS.
AFTER THIRTY YEARS OF SERVICE
MIKE RETIRED IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE BUT CONTINUE TO
VOLUNTEER HIS TIME AND
EXPERTISE TO COUNTLESS NUMBERS
OF ORGANIZATIONS. MIKE HAD A
PASSION FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND USED HIS CHP
DERIVED KNOWLEDGE TO BE
INEFFECTUAL LEADER AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
TWELLMAN COUNTY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. OF WHICH HE WAS A
MEMBER FOR A BOARD AS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD. AND AS THEIR
CHAIR FOR THREE YEARS. WHILE ME
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COUNCIL
AND MANY OTHERS. THE PANDEMIC
HAS TAKEN A TOLL ON ALL OF THIS.
AND HAS TAKEN THE LIVES OF SOME
OF THE BEST PEOPLE IN THIS
STATE. HOPEFULLY MANY PEOPLE
WILL USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR THE WORDS AND HOPEFULLY
SOON ALL GET VACCINATED. I
THINK MIKE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. SO THIS MEMORY DOESN'T GO
IN VAIN AND THE LOSS OF HIS
LIFE BECAUSE OF THIS DISEASE
IT'S NOT REALLY DISEASE IT'S A
VIRUS I MISSPOKE THERE. MIKE
MEMORY LIVES ON WITH HIS WIFE
OF FORTY SIX YEARS. NANCY HIS
TWO DAUGHTERS ERIN AND HEATHER
ALONG WITH FOUR GRANDCHILDREN
HIS SISTER HIS MOTHER. AND
VERIFY AND A WHOLE BUNCH OF.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY I ASK FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY OF MIKE.
I'LL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BIGELOW THANK YOU
MEMBERS. ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
RULES COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO UPON
ADJOURNMENT THAT'S RULES IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO. UPON
ADJOURNMENT AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING HERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER. AT TWO
THIRTY SHARP TWO THIRTY PM. ON
THE FLOOR SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY JANUARY
TWELFTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY JANUARY THIRTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
JANUARY FOURTEENTH CHECKING
SESSION FRIDAY JANUARY
FIFTEENTH FOR SESSION IS AT
NINE A. M. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING AND HEARING OF
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
HIS RANTS MOVES MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY JANUARY
FIFTEENTH AT NINE AM WE ARE
TURN.